the devils are some of the most powerful
creatures in the world of Black Clover
and in practically every single Arc of
the story the main villain is either a
devil a devil host or someone who has
been manipulated by a devil in this
video I will break down every known
devil in the Black Clover story
including their epic powers and
abilities and I will explain why these
devils are such a crucial part of the
series I've made content on devils in
Black Clover before but this video will
update everything we know as of the
final Arc of the story so let's get into
it you guys know the drill if you enjoy
my Black Clover videos and you want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment right now for that
YouTube algorithm and if you want to
help this channel attain wizard King
level by hitting 2 million subscribers
Please Subscribe right now subscribing
on YouTube is completely free and every
single subscription counts finally this
video will contain Black Clover manga
spoilers all the information in the
black lower manga regarding Devils is
fair game so please proceed with caution
you have been warned the devils are an
ancient race of powerful magical
creatures that reside in the Underworld
most of them appear to be cruel and
malevolent by nature and they take
pleasure in torturing other Devils who
are seen as beneath them as well as
toying with humans and other creatures
whenever they get the chance however
they don't get to toy with humans often
because devils are unable to leave the
underworld and enter the human world on
their own most of the time when a devil
manifests inside the human world it is
because a human Mage used forbidden
magic and a sacrificial ritual in order
to summon a devil and form a contract
with them in exchange for access to some
of the devil's Powers the gate between
the human world and the underworld
normally prevents all Devils from
physically climbing up to the human
world but the gate is designed to repel
creatures who possess magic in the rare
instance that a devil without any
magical powers appears he will be able
to pass through the gate easily in order
for a devil to use or possess a grimoire
it has to be a five leaf grimoire and
the only way for Devils to unleash their
full Powers outside the underworld is to
find a five-leaf grimoire and find a way
to fully manifest their physical body
into the human world due to the unique
nature of devil Mana many forms of human
magic have little to no effect on devils
in order for a human Mage to fight a
devil effectively they need to possess
Arcane stage magic Saint stage magic or
the magic of other Devils and of course
anti-magic is highly effective against
Devils which is good news for our boy
Asta the core of a devil's body is its
heart and as long as the heart is not
destroyed the devil will be able to
regenerate itself even if most of its
body is destroyed there is a hierarchy
among the Devils that can be divided
into four tiers at the bottom we have
low ranking Devils then mid-ranking
Devils then high ranking devils and
finally highest rank ranking Devils
which are also known as Supreme devils
in the viz translation in this video
we'll be covering every known Supreme
devil as well as every lower ranked
devil that plays a significant role in
the story we will not be covering
nameless low-ranked devil NPCs first up
we have zagreed the main villain of the
entire elf Saga zagrett is a
high-ranking devil who has been alive
for over 500 years he is extremely
powerful and has a massive amount of
Mana but he is not one of the Supreme
Devils he is one rank below that zagrett
was the one who orchestrated the elf
Massacre basically just before the elf
Massacre zagrett possessed the body of
one of clover Kingdom's ministers and he
manipulated the humans of the Clover
Kingdom to betray The Elves and attack
them during leaked and tetia's wedding
ceremony practically the entire elf
tribe was killed Tatia was seriously
injured and leaked became overwhelmed by
despair which transformed his four-leaf
grimoire into a five lead grimoire
zagreed then tried to take control of
leaked's overpowered and monologued body
but despite drowning in despair leaked
resisted with the help of the magic
Stones leaked transformed into a giant
demon and this prevented zagread from
being able to possess his body zagret
also tried to take control of leith's
five-leaf grimoire but Sucree used her
ceiling magic along with the magic
stones to seals a great away inside an
eternal prison but before the seal could
be completed zagrett was able to summon
the magic Stones himself and he used
them to make sure that the souls of the
murdered elves would be reincarnated in
the future this reincarnation finally
takes place five centuries later and
zagret eventually manipulates the
reincarnated elves into opening the
shadow Palace zagret is then able to
summon his original body up from the
underworld and this sets the stage for
the final showdown of the elf Saga
zagreed uses kotodama magic also known
as word so magic which is a type of
magic that allows him to alter physical
reality with his words he can manifest
swords monsters and many other magical
and non-magical weapons by simply
mentioning them verbally and he can also
manipulate a wide variety of objects and
living beings at will because he is such
a powerful devil most magic attributes
from this world have little to no effect
on him with some exceptions including
yami's dark magic and asta's anti-magic
Zagreb is eventually taken down by a
brilliant team effort that really
showcases how teamwork plays an
important role in Black Clover Asta Yami
and a bunch of other powerful warriors
including the first wizard King and
leaked all have to work together in
order to finally destroy zagret next up
let's talk about liebe the devil who
resides inside austa's five-leaf
grimoire and who possesses the rare
power known as anti-magic liebe was born
inside the underworld and allegedly he
was one of the lowest ranked Devils he
was born without any magic just like
Asta and this is an almost unheard of
occurrence in the Underworld due to his
lack of Magic the other Devils mocked
and bullied him and he was often a
victim of physical attacks one day he
was actually thrown up into the gate
that separates the underworld from the
human world by one of the other Devils
the devil who threw liebe was expecting
him to smash into the gate and die but
instead of smashing into it liebe passed
through the gate and ended up inside the
human world as I said earlier the gate
that separates the underworld from the
human world was specifically designed to
stop any being with magic from passing
through so because liebe had no magic he
was able to just pass through without
problems since the other Devils all had
magic none of them could follow liebe
into the human world and so he was
finally free from The Bullying of the
other Devils although being a devil in
the human world came with its own set of
unique challenges the Devils who live
inside the underworld fantasize about
finding a human host and entering the
human world through that host because
the underworld is dull and boring but
the human world is a lot more fun and
interesting to them they want to have
fun with humans manipulate them toy with
them and cause havoc and Chaos
everywhere they go but liebe was
different as a devil with no magic he
was nothing but a punching bag for the
other Devils and so he never had any
desire to become a bully himself by
attacking or manipulating humans
nevertheless even though liebit didn't
mean any harm to humans every human who
saw him in the human world was scared of
him because of everything they had known
about other Devils so the humans
immediately assumed that liebe had to be
dangerous and evil like his devil
Brethren and they summoned the magic
Knights to hunt leave it down and kill
him liebe was forced to go on the run
from the magic Knights who were trying
to hunt him down and eventually he
collapsed from exhaustion deep inside a
forest in the middle of nowhere liebe
thought that the humans would catch up
to him and kill him while he was
unconscious but to his surprise when he
woke up he found that a human woman
named lichita had taken him into her
home and was nursing him back to health
liebe was distrustful at first but
eventually he and nichita began to bond
and lichita ultimately decided to adopt
liebe and raise him as her own son this
human woman was also an outcast from
Human Society just like liebe was an
outcast from devil Society she was born
with a unique magical body that steals
magic and life force from every living
creature around her she is unable to
turn this power off and as a result she
was shunned from Human Society nobody
wants their life force or magic to be
drained so Lee had to live far away from
everyone else otherwise she would be
perceived as a threat and probably
attacked by the other humans but liebe
wasn't negatively affected by lychee
disability as a devil who doesn't have
any magic he was able to be close to
lichita without suffering any negative
consequences in time lichita and liebe
became like mother and son it is
eventually revealed that in the past
lichita was forced to give up her own
son presumably to protect him from the
negative effects of her magic and that
sun was none other than Asta himself
lichita was the one who gave Asta up at
the orphanage she didn't do it because
she didn't want him she did it in order
to protect him from her own life force
draining magic it's interesting that
after giving Asta up lichita ended up
raising asta's future devil liebe so the
two of them actually share the same
mother lichita is asked as biological
mother and liebe's adoptive mother
lichita and liebe lived humble but
heartwarming lives out there in the
middle of nowhere they minded their own
business and they didn't bother anyone
they just lived happily together as
mother and son unfortunately their
happiness wouldn't last because one day
a supreme Devil by the name of lucifero
discovered that liebe is a devil who has
been able to live inside the human world
without a human host lucifero decided
that he would take over liebe's body and
use liebe as his host within the human
world presumably having a devil host
inside the human world would make a
devil like lucifero even more powerful
than if he just had a normal human host
lucifero attempted to take over liebe's
body by force but lichita was able to
stop him unfortunately lichita was no
match for someone like lucifero so in
the process of saving her son she ended
up sacrificing her own life lichita was
able to use her absorption magic to
absorb a portion of lucifero's mana and
this forced lucifero to disappear before
more of his Mana could be absorbed but
before he disappeared he managed to give
lichita a fatal injury although she
managed to save liebe likita was dying
fully aware that her time was running
out legit I used her other ability the
ability to seal anything without magic
inside an inanimate object to seal liebe
inside a five-leaf grimoire that she had
in her possession this is how liebe
ended up inside that five-leaf grimoire
lichita knew that once he was sealed
inside the grimoire he would be saved
from future attacks by lucifero and
since she would no longer be around to
help him likita thought that this was
the only way to protect her son having
sealed liebe inside the five leaf
grimoire lichita passed away and liebe
spent years trapped inside he slowly
Grew Older and stronger but he also
spent all of his time inside the
grimoire plotting revenge against
lucifero and all the other Devils the
Devils had been tormenting him for his
entire life they took everything from
him they killed his mother and now they
were going to pay for some reason liba's
unique anti-magic abilities began to
manifest while he was stuck inside the
grimoire it's important to note that he
never had the ability to use anti-magic
before he entered the grimoire he was
simply a magless devil with no special
powers or abilities we don't know
exactly why anti-magic began manifesting
while liebe was trapped inside the
grimoire it might have been something as
simple as he was a late bloomer and
anti-magic was a latent ability that he
was always going to manifest or the
manifestation of anti-magic could have
been the result of lichita's absorption
magic mixing with the small amount of
lucifero's Mana that she was able to
absorb before she died maybe anti-magic
is actually the combination of lichita's
absorption magic and lucifero's gravity
magic reacting with each other after
they were sealed away inside the five
leaf grimoire this is just a theory
there is no confirmation for how or why
anti-magic actually came into being but
it's interest thing to think about after
the five-leaf grimoire chose Asta as its
user liebe's initial plan was to take
control of asta's body by force and use
it to get revenge on lucifero and the
other Devils but eventually Asta and
liebe decided to work together as equals
because liebe realized that Asta was not
his rival in fact Asta was his long-lost
adoptive brother and not only did they
share the same mother but they also
share a common enemy lucifero and the
devils and since lucifero played such an
important role in leave his backstory it
makes sense to talk about him next as I
mentioned earlier lucifero is one of the
highest ranking Devils also known as a
supreme devil and he resides at the very
lowest level of the underworld around
the time that he failed to take over
Libya's body lucifero made a contract
with a human hose by the name of Dante
zogratis the three zogratic siblings
that we meet initially make up the dark
Triad they are all devil hosts and they
used their devil magic to overthrow the
ruling House of the Spade King Kingdom
House grin very all and to take power
for themselves we eventually learned
that there is a fourth Socratic sibling
and he makes the first three siblings
look like petulant children but more on
him later chapter 286 reveals that the
underworld is ruled by three Devils one
uses time magic the other uses spatial
magic and the third uses gravity magic
lucifero is one of these three rulers of
the underworld and he is of course the
one who uses gravity magic as the name
suggests gravity magic allows the user
to manipulate gravity in a wide variety
of ways he's able to severely increase
the gravity in a particular area in an
instant forcing even the strongest Mages
to fall to the ground due to the
enormous pull of his gravity magic he
can even use gravity to warp physical
space in order to avoid attacks or
destroy the magic of his opponents and
his gravity magic can even affect
intangible Concepts such as dreams
lucifero has been referred to as the
king of devil and the strongest devil
connected to the tree of cliffhop and
yes his power is impressive even as an
incomplete manifestation with only half
of his power available he was able to
stand against many of the Clover
Kingdom's strongest magic Knights on his
own he is incredibly strong fast durable
and difficult to fight that said many
Black Clover fans were disappointed with
how lucifero ultimately went out he was
built up as a possible candidate for the
final villain in the entire series
especially since he had a history with
asta's mother and liebe and since he was
billed as one of the three rulers of the
underworld and the strongest Cliff off
devil however his partial manifestation
which had 50 of his full power was
ultimately defeated by the teamwork of
Asta yuno and a bunch of the strongest
magic Knight captains his heart was then
taken by another devil named Adara
Melech and delivered to the fourth
sogratis sibling Lucius zogratis later
on Lucius travel to the lowest level of
the underworld defeated the other half
of lucifero that was still stuck down
there and took the heart of this second
half as well so lucifero ultimately
failed to live up to expectations he
most certainly wasn't the final villain
in fact he got completely outmaneuvered
and humiliated by the final villain
someone whom lucifera would have looked
down upon as a mere human and that's the
other disappointing thing about lucifero
he was an extremely one-dimensional
villain and his entire personality was
that he believed himself to be a
superior being and that he looked down
upon everyone who was weaker than him
including lower ranked devils and All
Humans this led him to underestimate his
opponents and ultimately it led to
lucifero becoming just a tool for Lucius
who was able to absorb lucifero's heart
and his gravity magic along with it now
since I briefly mentioned adaramelik as
the devil who took lucifero's heart and
delivered it to Lucius in the human
world let's talk about this mysterious
devil right now
is also a supreme devil connected to the
tree of cliffhov although he seems to
reside on the second level of the
underworld rather than on the lowest
level like lucifero the interesting
thing about this devil is that he is not
like the majority of the other Devils
that we met in the story rather than
looking down on humans and wanting to
destroy them all for fun when he emerges
from the underworld he actually warns
the humans that they are in danger and
that they need to run away from lucifero
if they want to survive even crazier is
the fact that other Melech directly
defies lucifero's orders when lucifero
commands other Melech to help him fight
the humans he refuses the order and
continues to just watch the fight
without intervening This is highly
unusual because lucifero is regarded as
the king of the devils and one of the
rulers of the underworld he certainly
does have the authority to command
someone like adaramelic and yet
adaramelik still disobeys the order
without a second thought when the humans
eventually win the battle against ola
odds other America applauds them for
their accomplishment and he then
proceeds to take lucifero's heart
lucifero's heart is what other amalek
was after all along and he eventually
travels to the wizard King's office
inside the Clover Kingdom capital in
order to deliver the heart directly to
Lucius zogradis other Melech does seem
to be loyal to Lucius for whatever
reason because under lucius's command he
was sent out on a mission to act as a
diversion along with a bunch of other
devil NPCs however even then other
Melech seems to have avoided fighting
the humans and he was said to be only
evading attacks he also looked like he
was bored throughout the entire Mission
proving once again that he doesn't seem
to have any violent inclinations towards
humans most of the other Devils would
have loved an opportunity to go out and
kill a bunch of humans for fun but for
whatever reason other Melech is
different so yeah this is a really
strange one and I personally can't wait
to find out more about this devil in
particular we still don't know his
backstory his true intentions or his
magic abilities but clearly Tabata
introduced him into the story for a
reason so I'm sure that more will be
revealed about other Melech before the
story ends speaking of devils who don't
mean harm to humans let's talk about the
four mid-ranked Devils who made a
contract with knocked the vice captain
of the black Bulls as mid-ranking Devils
these four are not among the weakest
Devils but they are also nowhere near
the Supreme Devils when it comes to
power as a member of the noble Faust
family which had been secretly studying
devils and forbidden magic for
Generations knocked was able to gain
access to these four Devils at a very
young age and due to his exceptional
talent for devil magic he was able to
make contracts with all four of them
each devil has a chibi form as a devil
familiar and a larger form which is
based on an animal the four Devils
include gimodelo whose appearance is
based on a dog and whose unite mode with
knocked is called Kanis when in Kanis
mode knocked can use an ability called
Peck which allows him to basically
generate a bunch of Shadow clones then
we have slotos whose appearance is based
on a horse and whose unite mode with
knocked is called ekus the this mode
functions like a powerful shadow armor
that makes knocked tougher and more
resilient it is an excellent defensive
technique that allows knocked to
withstand a lot more damage than he can
normally sustain in addition knocked can
use unite mode Connie's X ekus to
assimilate both gimodelo and slotos into
his body at the same time using Shadow
Magic this allegedly allows the Devils
to raise their magic up to the rank of a
supreme devil next up we have plumede
whose appearance is based on a cat and
whose unite mode with knock is called
felis this mode allows noct to use
incredible Speed and Agility in order to
run circles around his opponents knock
can use unite mode Connie's X valleys to
assimilate both gimodelo and blue mede
at the same time finally we have Walgren
whose appearance is based on a rooster
and whose unite mode with knocked is
called galus this mode allows knock to
unleash a loud cry that has the power to
paralyze his opponents knocked is able
to use unite mode galusex valleys to
assimilate both Wagner and plumede at
the same time it is important to note
that while knocked believes that
combining two mid-ranked Devils like
Wagner and plumande allows him to wield
the power of a supreme devil that
doesn't necessarily mean that he can
actually defeat a supreme devil in this
state some Supreme devils are of course
stronger than others and when knocked
tries to fight the Supreme Devil's
Lilith and Nama in his galus X fail his
form he is soundly defeated by their
devil ice and Devil Fire magic
thankfully knocked was able to buy line
of time for Asta to arrive and back him
up speaking of Lilith and Nama let's
talk about these two supreme Devils next
the two of them appear to be twins with
Lilith having the appearance of a woman
and namah having the appearance of a man
they were both released into the human
world from the top level of the
underworld Lilith possesses devil ice
magic and Nama possesses Devil Fire
magic these are not normal forms of Fire
and Ice magic rather they are special
and overpowered devil versions of these
magic attributes and they are able to
freeze and burn everything not only can
they burn and freeze physical matter but
they can even burn and freeze things
without any physical substance such as
Light Shadows and darkness Lilith and
Nama both appear to be complete psychos
who love toying with weaker creatures
including humans they entertain
themselves by overpowering and
tormenting other life forms because
these two Devils reside on the top level
of the underworld just like liebe once
did and because they each possess one
oversized arm some believe that the
devil who threw liebe into the human
world was one of these two supreme
Devils after Asta manages to slash
through nama's body with the Demon
Slayer sword Lilith proceeds to fuse her
own body with Namaz creating a fused
final form this fused devil has the
ability to use both devil ice and Devil
Fire magic and he can also combine the
two magic attributes at will he is also
much stronger and has much more magic
power than the sum of Lilith and the
Moss Powers when they are separated into
distinct entities basically this Fusion
doesn't just create a devil whose power
is equal to the sum of Lilith and the ma
rather the fused devil is exponentially
stronger than Lilith and Nama were but
thanks to some creative teamwork from
Knocked and devil Union Asta the heroes
are able to deal with this monstrous
fused devil form now let's talk about
another Supreme devil who is considered
to be one of the three rulers of the
underworld along with lucifero the name
of the this devil is Beelzebub and his
magic allows him to manipulate the
fabric of space itself in short he
possesses an overpowered form of spatial
magic and when we first meet this devil
his human host is Xenon zogratis
piazepam resides on the lowest level of
the underworld along with lucifero and
the third ruler but I'll talk more about
the third ruler in a little bit
unfortunately we don't know anything
about beelzebub's personality because he
only appears in the story as a source of
power being used by a devil host
initially his host is Xenon but after
Lucius zagratus takes control of the
Supreme devils in the Underworld
Beelzebub is purified and incarnated
inside of Paladin Lily allowing Lily to
use powerful spatial magic the Elsa Pub
is named after a demon who exists in
various religious traditions and
mythologies of our own world and he is
often referred to as the Lord of the
Flies however the Beelzebub from Black
Clover doesn't really seem to have
anything in common with the Beelzebub
from our own world other than the name
but what about that mysterious third
ruler of the underworld well during the
course of the Black Clover Story the
third ruler of the underworld is the
Supreme devil megikula a devil who
possesses powerful curse wording magic
and who was initially introduced to the
story through its human host vanica
zogradis megikula is extremely
interested in humans and that is to say
she is extremely interested in
experimenting on humans in order to
determine what effects her curse wording
magic will have on a wide variety of
human bodies she doesn't actually value
human lives or anything she just enjoys
toying with humans and experimenting on
them but she has no qualms about killing
a human once she loses interest in them
that said make equalize fascinated by
unique types of magic such as Arcane
stage magic and Elemental Spirit magic
many years ago Gordon's family made a
contract with megikula in order to
conduct research on curses so she has
been getting involved in human Affairs
Beyond just her host vanica in fact
magical is believed to have been
interfering with the human world since
ancient times and all Cursed Magic in
the world is said to have come from her
magikula is the one who cursed Noel's
mother asier Silva as well as Princess
lopeshka from the heart Kingdom
magikula's curse magic is so powerful
that it can take down Arcane Mages and
it can even affect Elemental Spirits her
curses are extremely effective in
harming her opponents and weakening
their spells on top of curse magic
megiko is also able to use blood magic
and steel magic because she had control
of vanika and Asia's souls or at least
she did before Lucius kind of turned the
tables on all the Devils the interesting
thing about megikulov is that she was
referred to as the third ruler of the
underworld along with lucifero and
Beelzebub which kind of makes sense
because the three rulers on the
underworld chose the three members of
the dark Triad as their hosts
nevertheless originally the three rule
of the underworld were lucifero who
possesses gravity magic Beelzebub who
possesses spatial magic and asteroth who
possesses Thai magic at some point
asteroth mysteriously disappeared from
the lowest level of the underworld and
megikula is just a replacement for him
she is not one of the three original
rulers of the underworld she's like a
substitute but before we talk about
astorov let us first cover lucifugus
another Supreme devil who has a long and
dark history with the Faust family of
which knocked and his brother Morgan are
members years ago the Faust family
believed that knocked was talented
enough to bind lucifugus because he had
already been able to bind for lesser
Devils on his own Morgan tried to stop
his brother from attempting something so
dangerous but not refused to listen and
he summoned the Supreme devil lucifugus
but knocked attempts to suppress and
bind the Supreme devil were useless and
lucifugus proceeded to kill everyone
present add the ritual including every
member of the Faust family the only one
who survives in the end is knocked
himself because Morgan sacrificed his
own life in order to stop the ritual and
send lucifugus back into the underworld
and so Morgan dies but knocked survives
leading knock to feel guilty for the
rest of his life if he had only listened
to Morgan then Morgan would still be
alive but because knocked didn't listen
Morgan died unfortunately we don't know
anything about Lucifer was beyond this
we don't even know what his magic
attribute is another Supreme devil that
we know very little about is Bal who was
incarnated by Lucius into the body of
damnnatio Kira during the final Arc ball
possesses air magic which allows him to
manipulate the air and create nearly
unbreakable invisible barriers finally
let's talk about the time magic devil
asteroth the mysterious third ruler of
the underworld who somehow disappeared
from the lowest level and then was
replaced by megikula in chapter 330 33
we learned that asteroth had been
successfully bound to the fourth zograta
sibling Lucius who was born with two
Souls inside of one body somehow
asteroth made a contract with both
Lucius and Julius allowing both of them
to use Thai magic but while that itself
could make sense what doesn't make sense
is the fact that we never actually get
to see asteroth in any way despite the
fact that he has a human host Lucius
Julius and despite the fact that his
time magic has been used by them we
never even see so much as a silhouette
of asteroth since we know that asteroth
is one of the three rulers of the
underworld you would think that he would
have a pretty big personality and that
he would want to engage with the human
world in the same way that so many other
Supreme Devils do and yet Tabata has
chosen to keep everything about asteroth
a mystery including his appearance his
personality and how he became bound to
Lucius Julius in the first place since
the truth about Azeroth remains a giant
mystery as of the making of this video I
can't provide any more definitive
answers at this time but there are some
interesting theories out there about
asteroth's true identity and why Tabata
is still keeping everything about him a
secret some believe that asteroth is
asta's Father no normal human could be
with lichita because of her dangerous
absorption magic so Austin's father
could be something other than human he
could be a devil and maybe this
combination of devil and human genetics
is what led to the genetic anomaly that
left Asta as the only human born without
any magic there there is also the theory
that Julius took asteroth's magic and
then separated the devil's Soul into two
parts
these two parts of his soul were then
reincarnated as hasta and liebe a human
born without magic and a devil born
without magic they were both born
without magic because they are the
reincarnations of a devil whose magic
was stolen by Julius Lucius and since he
no longer possesses any magic neither do
his two reincarnations and the theories
only get crazier from there but I'm sure
that by the end of the Black Clover
story we will finally find out the truth
about asteroth and about asta's father
those are literally the two greatest
Unsolved Mysteries that still remain in
the series now tell me this who is your
favorite devil in Black Clover and what
is your favorite devil magic attribute
in the series let me know down below if
you're looking for another epic Black
Clover video to watch next check out my
theory video on why Asta and liebe could
be two halves of the time double
asteroth link on screen and in the
description if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see Black Clover content
in the future leave a quick like to let
me know and if you want to help us
become an Arcane stage anime channel by
hitting 2 million subscribers Please
Subscribe right now subscribing on
YouTube is completely free and every
subscription counts